hi I'm Jan 11 I'm an astrophysicist and
I've been asked to explain gravity in
five levels of increasing complexity
gravity seems so familiar and so
everyday and yet it's this incredibly
esoteric abstract subject that has
shaped the way we view the universe on
the largest scales has given us the
strangest phenomena in the universe like
black holes that has changed the way we
look at the entirety of physics it's
really been a revolution because of
gravity are you interested in science
yes yes you are yes do you know what
gravity is it's something that so right
now there was no gravity but since
there's gravity we're sitting right down
on these chairs that's pretty good so
gravity wants to attract us to the earth
and the earth to us but the earth is so
much bigger that even though we're
actually pulling the earth a little bit
to us you don't notice it so much you
know the moon pulls on the earth a
little bit just like with the ocean
tides exactly the moon is such a big
body compared to anything else very
nearby then it has the larger effect
pulling the water of the earth but more
than the moon think about the Sun
pulling on the earth we orbit the whole
Sun just the way the earth pulls on the
moon and causes the moon to orbit us all
of those things are electing on you and
me right now gravity was too strong will
we be able to get up that's such a good
question no we actually couldn't the
moon gravity is weaker can almost float
between footsteps if you look at the
astronauts on the moon on the earth it's
harder because it's bigger if you go to
a bigger heavier planet it gets harder
and harder but there are stars that have
died that are so dense that there's no
way we could lift our arms no way we
could step or walk but the gravity is
just way too strong do you know how tall
you are I mean the force in the force
maybe for three people think that while
you're sleeping your body has a chance
to stretch out and grab
crunching you together but when you're
standing and walking or sitting that
gravity contracts your spine ever so
slightly so that in the morning you
might be a little bit taller than in the
evening see if it works for you yes they
say that astronauts in space definitely
their spinal long gates there were two
twin astronauts one who stayed here on
earth and the other who went to the
International Space Station it was there
for a long time and when he came back he
was actually taller than his twin
brother yeah and that was because
gravity wasn't compressing him all the
time and he was floating freely in the
International Space Station and his
spine just kind of elongated after a
while here on earth though he'll
readjust they'll go back to the same
size have you ever heard of how cavity
was discovered Isaac Newton would ponder
how does the earth cause things to fall
there's a famous story that Isaac Newton
was sitting under a tree and the apple
fell from the tree and hit him on the
head and he had an epiphany and
understood this law this mathematical
law for how that works I don't actually
think it's a true story but it's a good
story so Isaac Newton who realized that
even if you're heavier you will fall at
the same rate as something much lighter
that that's the same once you hit the
ground if you're heavier you'll hit the
ground with much greater force but you
will hit the ground at the same time so
if we both drop down from the plane we
would both wind at the same time but you
would land heavier yep so like a penny
from the Empire State Building will fall
at the same rate as a bowling ball yeah
amazing
want to try it oh yeah a light object
see how light that is
that's very late and a heavy object they
look the same but this is much heavier
right okay so try it just try holding
your arms out
and a little higher maybe give him a
chance to drop and then drop them did
they fall at the same time did he hit at
the same time so Isaac Newton he was
also the one who realized that that's
the same force that keeps the moon in
orbit around the Earth on the earth in
orbit around the Sun and that's a huge
leap here he is looking at just things
around him and then looks at the Stars
and has this really big realization that
that's actually the same force so what
have you learned today talking about
gravity I've learned that the person
that learned about the Apple Newton um
he was learning about gravity just about
what he saw on this planet I also
learned that if you drop one light thing
one heavy thing at the same height at
the same time they're both gonna drop at
the same time but one's gonna drop a
little heavier than the other that's
beautiful
I'm impressed so Rio you're in high
school yeah I'm a junior and are you
studying any Sciences in high school I'm
taking physics and do you think of
yourself as curious about science well
they're like some things that interest
me and how is that for me is what it
like depends what interests you well
like I'm a gymnast selling in physics
they talk about like force and stuff and
then I think of like how I use physics
and like my own life what's your
impression of what gravity is I think
that if there's like no gravity I really
like float everywhere it like pulls
things down and without it like
everything would just be like chaos so
you're saying gravity pulls things down
yet we've launched things into space
have you ever wondered how we do that
that's it like a slingshot like if you
put something back enough it'll to go in
the opposite direction
well that's true we do use slingshot
technology once things are out in the
solar system so for instance we use
Jupiter and other planets so that when
some of the spacecraft gets close
it'll slingshot around and it'll cause
it to like speed up but mostly around
the earth gravity pulls things down so
when we want to send a rocket into space
and we want to go to the moon
some supplies to the International Space
Station the trick is to get something
moving fast enough that it escapes the
gravitational pull of the earth have you
heard the expression what goes up must
come down it's actually not true if you
throw it fast enough you can actually
get something that doesn't come back
down again and that's basically how
rocket launches work you have to get the
rocket for the earth to go more than 11
kilometers a second think of how fast it
is just one breath and it's gone 11
kilometers if you get it to go that fast
it's not gonna come back down again so
you know the International Space Station
where which is orbiting the Earth that's
going around the earth at like 17,000
miles an hour it has no engines anymore
the engines are turned off so it's just
they're falling forever so once it's out
there it's not coming back down as long
as it's cruising like that and like does
the gravity part and it is just like in
a weird way that is gravity pulling it
so have you ever um had a yo-yo where
you swing it around like this the string
is pulling it in at all times but you've
also given it this angular momentum and
as long as you give it the angular
momentum pulling it in actually keeps it
in orbit and so the earth is pulling it
in at all times so that's why it doesn't
just travel off in a straight line it
keeps coming back around so it's funny
people think that the International
Space Station is so far away that
they're not feeling gravity and that's
not the case at all they're absolutely
feeling gravity they're just cruising so
fast that even though they're being
pulled in they never get pulled to the
surface it's like that the roller
coaster is really yeah you go in and it
spins super fast and you can't feel it
spinning fast yeah you feel pinned to
that it's exactly like that there's
something called the equivalence
principle where people realized and
specially Einstein that if you were in
outer space in a rocket ship and it was
dark and painted and it was accelerating
at exactly the right rate you actually
wouldn't know if you were sitting on the
floor of a building around the Earth or
if you want a rocket ship that was
accelerating it's crazy
you ever had that experience where
you're sitting in a train and the other
one moves and for a second you're not
sure if you're the one moving yeah cuz I
don't train
go to school I never feel like I'm
moving when I'm in the chain and I'm
like wait what that's because in some
sense you're really not imagine you're
in this chain and it's going near the
speed of light relative to the platform
but it's so smooth then you should be in
a situation in which there's no meaning
to your absolute motion there's no
absolute motion so that if you throw a
ball up you might think from the outside
of the platform be confused that when
gravity pulls that back down it's going
to hit you or something but it'll land
in your palm as surely as if you were in
your living room it's not kind of easy
so imagine you are an astronaut you are
floating in empty space so you can't see
anything there's no stars there's no
earth you can ask yourself am i moving
just really no way for you to tell so
you would probably conclude well I'm not
having so then your friend marina comes
cruising past you and maybe she's going
thousands of kilometers a second and you
say marina you're cruising it like
thousands of kilometres a second you're
going so fast but she had just done the
same experiment she was just floating in
space thinking you know am i moving
there's no way to know which one of you
is moving and there's no meaning to the
absolute motion the only thing that's
true is that you're in relative motion
that's true you both agree you were in
relative motion and that's clear but
neither of you can say it's actually you
who's moving and I'm stationary I don't
even know what to say to that so let me
tell you where it gets really crazy so
let's say you and marina are floating in
space and you can't tell who's moving
let's say you both see a flash of light
the flash of light comes from somewhere
you don't know where so you measure the
speed of light to be 300,000 kilometers
per second
but here comes marina and she's racing
at the light pulse as far as you can
tell two cars driving towards each other
seem like they're going faster towards
each other than somebody who's standing
still relative to one of the cars right
so you would say Oh marinas gonna
measure a difference be like but she
comes back and she's it's no 300,000
kilometers per second because from her
perspective she's standing still and the
laws of physics had better be the same
for her the speed of light is a fact of
nature that says true as the strength of
gravity
and the two of you are in this quandary
because of one of you is the preferred
person who correctly measures the speed
of light that ruins everything about the
idea of the relativity of motion which
one of you should it be so Einstein
decides they must both measure the same
speed of light how could that possibly
possibly be the case and he thinks well
if speed is how far you travel your
spatial distance in a certain amount of
time then there must be something wrong
with space and time and he goes from the
constancy of the speed of light and a
respect for this idea of relativity to
the idea that space and time must not be
the same for you and for marina and
that's how he gets the idea of the
relativity of space and time
you're the best expression it's pretty
wild but that is a starting point
actually of the whole theory of
relativity that starting point leads to
this complete revolution in physics
where we suddenly have a Big Bang in
black holes and space-time just from
that one simple starting point so is
your impression of gravity different
than when we started the conversation
yeah cuz like I knew that like when I
was on the train I didn't feel like I
was moving but I didn't know like why
and that it was a thing and I wasn't
crazy yeah and it's really deep
principle and what about the theory of
gravity I don't know like usually when I
just heard gravity it's like for my
coaches but I didn't know like it was
like all these things mm-hmm it's like a
big paradigm so you're in college yeah
what are you studying in college I'm a
physics major so from your perspective
how would you describe gravity I'm
taught that it's a force it's described
by inverse law but I also know that the
field and there's a recent discovery
with like gravitational waves although I
don't like the specific details of that
about that so when you say it's an
inverse square law yeah that means that
the closer you are yeah the more
strongly you feel the gravitational pull
yeah that makes sense
yes very few things that are stronger
when you're further apart yeah so you
can also think of a gravitational field
something that permeates all of space
the earth
three stories below us it's not as
though it's pulling at us from a
distance
right we're actually interacting with
the field at this point and there's a
real interaction right here at this
point and that's nice because people
were worried that if things acted at a
distance yeah that the way the old
fashioned inverse-square force law
describes it that it was as spooky as
like mind-bending a spoon that it was
like telekinesis you know if you don't
touch something how do you affect it and
so the first step was to start to think
of gravity as a field that permeates all
of space and it's weaker very far from
the earth and it's stronger very close
to the earth so one way to think of this
field is as a field that's really
describing a curved space-time that is
everywhere forget the difficulty of the
math just the intuition comes from two
kind of simple observations one was what
Einstein described as the happiest
thought of his life so right now you
might feel heavy in your chair and we
might feel heavy on the floor in our
feet or standing in an elevator cab and
Einstein would have said what does it
chair you have to do with it or the
floor or the elevator
those aren't gravitational objects and
so he wanted to eliminate them and one
way to do the thought experiment is to
imagine standing in an elevator that you
can't see out of a black box and imagine
the cable is cut and you and the
elevator begin to fall so I'm free fall
you're in total free fall now because
things fall at the same rate yeah
including the elevator and you yeah you
can actually float in the elevator if
you just float it in the elevator the
two of you would drop and you might not
even know it you're falling you can take
an apple and drop it in front of you and
it would float in front of you you would
actually experience weightlessness it's
called the equivalence principle it was
Einstein's happiest thought that what
you're really doing when you're
experiencing gravity isn't being heavy
in your chair it's falling weightlessly
in the gravitational field and that was
the first step to think of gravity as
weightlessness and falling I know like
as your gravity experienced
you're done with planes Emily yeah
exactly yeah you can make somebody look
like they're in the International Space
Station by flying up in a plane and then
just free-falling
the plane just drops out of the air and
while it's falling they will float
weightlessly and there's been a lot of
experiments about it but you don't want
it to end unhappily so the play has to
scoop back up yeah and then you see them
become pinned to the floor of the ball
okay because then the plane is
interrupting their fall so that's the
first thought and then the next is what
is the shape that's changed so if you
are floating in empty space really empty
space yeah and you had an apple and you
threw the Apple what shape do you think
it would chase the path well if I threw
it straight I would think it would go
it's straight yeah it would just go
straight but if you did that on the
earth what would happen it would just go
down yeah but it would call it with
tracing curved oh yeah Jason Hart
yeah and the faster you throw it you
look kind of longer the arc so the
second step to thinking about curved
spacetime is to say that when things
fall freely around a body like the earth
they trace curved paths as those
space-time itself space itself was
curved and so so that's the intuition
that's how Einstein gets from thinking
that space-time is curved from the idea
that well there's just field that
permeates all of space and what it's
really describing is the curves that
things fall along and from there it's a
very long path to finding the
mathematics and the right description
that's really hard but that intuition is
so elegant and so beautiful and just
comes from these two simple thought
experiments that's amazing isn't it kind
of a so you described learning in a
class about light the theory of special
relativity or Einstein is really
adhering to the constancy of the speed
of light and questioning the absolute
nature of space and time and it seems
like that has nothing to do with gravity
but he later begins to think about the
incompatibility of gravity with his
theory of relativity so suppose the Sun
were to disappear tomorrow from like
evil genius comes and just figures out a
way to evaporate the Sun in Newton's
understanding of gravity we would
instantaneously know about it all the
way over here at the earth and that's
incompatible with the concept that
nothing can travel faster than the speed
of light no information not even
information about the Sun could possibly
travel faster than the speed of light so
we shouldn't know about what happened to
the Sun for a full eight minutes which
is the time it would take light to
travel to us and so he begins to
question why gravity is so incompatible
with relativity but he already knows
he's thinking about space and time in
relativity so then he gets to his
general theory of relativity where he
realizes if I eliminate everything but
just the gravitational field of let's
say the earth and I look at how things
fall and I see that they follow curves
well then he realizes that space and
time don't just contract or dilate that
they can really warp that they can bend
him that they can curve and then he
finds a way to make gravity compatible
with relativity by saying if the Sun
were to disappear tomorrow the curves
that the Sun imprinted in space-time
would actually be into ripple and those
are the gravitational waves and they
would change and they would flatten out
because the Sun was no longer there yeah
that would take the light travel time to
get to us to tell us that the Sun was
gone uh-huh and then we would stop
orbiting and just travel along a
straight line Wow Wow so what do you
think you walk away with what do you
think you learned well more about the
intuitions behind the concept because we
already just do with the problems but
sometimes you get lost in a math but
like speaking like this it's really
helps build my intuition yeah it just it
does for me too
so thank you
[Music]
so you're getting your PhD in physics
that's right
theoretical high-energy physics
basically the physics of really really
small fundamental things so what would
that have to do with gravity or
astrophysics
well what I'm looking at is states of
matter that might exist inside neutron
stars so when a star dies if the star is
massive enough there's a huge explosion
called a supernova and the stuff that's
left behind that doesn't get blown away
collapses into a tiny compact blob
called a neutron star so what I love
about neutron stars personally is that
they're kind of City sized that's right
about the size of a city so you're
imagining something more than the mass
of the Sun yep or about the mass of a
Sun condensed to the size of a city it's
dense enough that one teaspoonful would
weigh about a billion tons here on earth
no that makes the gravitational field
incredibly strong that's right around
the neutron star so what would happen if
we were on a neutron star because we
would immediately be crushed into the
ground I think our bodies would be shred
into their subatomic particles so what's
the connection between neutron stars and
black holes so as I understand it a
black hole sort of like a neutron stars
big brother it's more intense if you
have so much matter when a star is
collapsing that it can't hold itself up
it collapses to a black hole and those
are so dense that space-time breaks down
in some way or another
black holes are so amazing that where
the neutron star stops and there's
something actually there right there's a
material there if it's very heavy it
becomes a black hole so it keeps falling
once the event horizon of the black hole
forms which is the shadow the curve
that's so strong that not even light can
escape the material keeps falling and
like you said maybe space-time breaks
down right at the center there but
whatever happens the star is gone that
black hole is empty so in a weird way
black holes are a place and not a thing
so is there a sensible way to talk about
what's inside a black hole or is that
should you think of it as there is no
space-time there isn't a sensible way to
talk about it yet and that probably
means that's where Einstein's theory of
gravity as a curved space-time is
beginning to break down and we need to
take the extra step of go
took some kind of quantum theory of
gravity and we don't have that yet so
even though the black hole isn't
completely understood we do know that
they form astronomically that in the
universe things like neutron stars form
and things like black holes form the
consequences are very much speaking to
this curved space-time so for instance
of two black holes orbit each other
they're like mallets on a drum and they
actually cause space-time to ring and
it's very much part of gravitation the
ringing of space-time itself we call
gravitational waves and that's what's
what's something Einstein thought about
right away in 1915 1916 he was thinking
about that those waves are very exciting
for me too because neutron stars
orbiting each other also give off
gravitational waves and we might be able
to get some data about neutron star
material from that kind of signal yes
the ring space-time also like a drum and
you can record the sound of that ringing
after a billion years when it's traveled
through the universe but then the next
thing that happens is those neutron
stars collide and because of this
incredibly high energy state of matter
which you study it becomes this firework
of different explosions it's really
quite spectacular that's right in fact
when we recorded that for the first time
with gravitational waves we then pointed
telescopes at it and were able to see it
optically as well and that gave
scientists a lot of data yeah it was um
to my knowledge the most widely studied
astronomical event in the history of
humanity Wow
so where the gravitational waves were
recorded and they realized oh this
sounds like you can reconstruct the
shape and size of the mallets of the
drum from the sound these sounds like
neutron stars colliding not black holes
and so like you said there was a trigger
for satellites and experiments all over
the world to point roughly in the
direction that the sound was coming from
so from your point of view I mean
they're like two superconducting giant
magnets colliding an experiment you
could never do on earth that's just of
the most tremendous scales and
peculiarities of matter absolutely I've
heard statistics like many earth masses
worth of gold or created forged in the
yeah a neutron star collision that
that we used to think that most elements
in the universe were created in
supernovae which is when stars explode
because there's so much violent activity
at the center that you need that kind of
energy to create new elements the way
you do in a bomb it's basically nuclear
fusion sure but we now think that that
kind of fusion happens when two neutron
stars collide if you think about it you
have two massive blobs of neutrons when
you smoosh them together
you've got neutrons colliding it creates
the conditions where new elements can be
created that's amazing it's literally
populating the periodic table yes we now
think that most of the heavy elements
after some number are created in neutron
star collisions so you are already a PhD
student you know a lot about gravity but
what do you think you've taken away from
this conversation well I've definitely
taken away that the way that we think
about gravity today is very different
from how Newton thought about it and
that even though we have a very good
understanding there's lots of things
that we don't fully understand there's
still a lot of questions to be answered
which i think is really exciting see
you're a scientist isn't the best part
being able to ask the questions oh yeah
so we've been talking about gravity from
Newton and celestial bodies the earth
the moon pulling on each other in the
conventional sense of gravity being an
attractive force to the earth creating
curves in space-time then we moved on to
just diffuse seeds of energy and
space-time as the real universe and
gravitation is really just talking about
space-time in general and here we are
and you're really hardcore in
theoretical physics where would you take
the exposition of gravity from that
point well one thing is quantum
mechanics quantum mechanics it's the
most accessible theory in the history of
science it explains the most different
phenomena the most precisely yet many
people would still say we don't
understand even the basics of it so when
we think about quantum mechanics we
think about particles and their quantum
charges and in the Fineman way the way
that Fineman taught us you know come in
and they exchange a forest carrier and
then they come out again so that's how
we think of an electron and light
scattering for instance or something
like that and the language that Einstein
gave us is so different it's completely
geometric it's all of this space-time
and it's also unnecessary yeah for me
the the beauty of the theory of gravity
is is the way Einstein formulated it as
a theory of geometry of curved space and
time I think like you that's one of the
things that really pulled me into it is
there really space-time or are we just
using unnecessary language because it's
elegant and we like it and it's
beautiful
well I think there is really space time
in the sense that it's a description
that works really well so there has to
be something right about it I mean if
we're gonna talk about what's really
really underlying that yeah and we're
gonna put quantum mechanics into the mix
then there should be some quantum
mechanical wave function for space 9 you
should be able to take two different
space times and add them together
because one of the crazy things about
quantum mechanics as you know is its
together yeah any two states any two
possible states of the world you can
just literally put a plus sign between
them and that's a that's a sensible
state that's a good state make sense so
do you think there's some sense in which
we shouldn't be thinking about
individual universes individual
space-time so we should be thinking
about superposition subspace please yeah
think so I think if you were to go far
enough back in the history of the
universe back to when it was very very
dense very small and when quantum
mechanics was certainly important then
it must have been like that I mean if we
believe that the dominant standard model
of cosmology something had to produce
the density perturbations the things
that seeded all the galaxies and stars
and us everything else in the world so
there's a galaxy over there let's say
and not over there so how did that
happen why is there galaxies they are
not there in the standard theory as you
know that was a quantum event a random
event yeah and it doesn't mean that it
happened they're not there because you
flipped a coin it actually happened in
both places there's got to be a
wavefunction where in one branch of the
wave function is galaxies they're not
there and any other branch it's the
opposite so when we're talking about the
multiverse or the Big Bang we are really
talking about gravity ultimately and
we're talking about how a theory of
gravitation which we now think of as a
theory of space-time has a quantum
explanation has a quantum paradigm
imposed on it that will help us
understand these things and we don't
have that yet one of the things that I
think is so amazing is that the terrains
in which we're going to understand
quantum gravity are very few right it's
the Big Bang because that's where we
know that quantum and gravity both were
called into action and there's black
holes one of the most interesting
discoveries of course Hawking's
discovery kick-started a kind of crisis
right in thinking about why quantum
mechanics and gravity were so knocking
heads it was one of the most beautiful
examples sure yeah it's it is a
beautiful beautiful idea so first of all
to be totally clear that we've never
observed Hawking radiation which is what
he predicted directly I don't think very
many people doubt that it's there but
yeah how can you discover it
mathematically that's when you have a
black hole it's got an event horizon
it's got a surface which is a point of
no return if you fall through that
surface no matter what you have no
matter how powerful of a rocket you got
even if you beam a flashlight back
behind you in the direction you fall
from nothing escapes not even like it
all gets sucked in and spaghettified and
destroyed at the singularity or
something something happens it doesn't
get out but in quantum mechanics you
can't really pin down the location of
something for cisely if you try to pin
down an electron and a tiny circuit and
a microchip sometimes you discover that
it's not actually there and then your
computer crashes this is the Heisenberg
uncertainty principle in reality you
can't precisely say
where the electron is and you can't
precisely say how quickly it's moving
exactly yeah so when you get the blue
screen of death that might be because of
quantum physics you know you try to pin
something down near a black hole well
it's a surface it's got a particular
radius for a round black hole and you
want to say something is inside or
outside well you can't absolutely say
that quantum mechanics and this kind of
uncertainty produces a radiation which
you can think of as pulling some of the
energy out of the black hole the black
hole was formed out of some mass and
there's an energy in that you can think
of pulling some energy out of that and
sending it off to infinity in the form
of particles being emitted yeah and what
Hawking found is that it's a thermal
spectrum it looks like a hot or not so
hot for a large black well but like an
oven the kind of radiation that comes
out of it cast iron this idea that the
darkest phenomena in the universe
actually is forced to radiate quantum
particles it's pretty wild I think
everyone understood that the that it was
a correct calculation but I don't think
a lot of people understood the
implications that it meant something
really terrible was happening because
this black hole which could have been
made of who knows what is disappearing
into these quantum particles which in
some sense have nothing to do with the
material who went in so do you think
that's a big crisis the black hole
evaporates the information is lost it's
a crisis because of some of the details
of it but I would say the way you just
described it I mean if I build a big
bonfire or an incinerator and I throw an
encyclopedia into it good luck
reconstructing what was in that inside
information is lost for all practical
purposes practical fair yes so this is a
huge crisis because either quantum
mechanics is wrong and as you described
it's the most accurately tested paradigm
in the history of physics how could it
be wrong right or the event horizon is
letting information out and violating
one of the most sacred principles of
relativity one thing about quantum
mechanics is that anytime you have a
state of the world and another state of
the world you can you can literally add
them together and get a third possible
status raises that sounds and so if
you're going to have a quantum theory of
gravity
then we can't really talk about there
being a black hole or not a black hole
hmm right or an event resident or not oh
this isn't because we could always take
a state that had an event horizon and a
state that doesn't or has the event
horizon in a slightly different position
maybe and add them together so the
existence or position of an event
horizon can't possibly be you know
determined as a fact anymore than the
position of electron is determined so I
think that's the loophole that's a nice
way of looking at it so that you're not
actually violating classical relativity
once you're in a regime where the
wavefunction has really peaked around a
very well-defined stage that's right I'm
whatever one of the most exciting
developments in the last 10 or 20 years
is called holography and it's called
holography because a hologram is a
two-dimensional surface it's a
three-dimensional image it's got sort of
3d information built into it right and
this in a fundamental way really has
that freedom for a higher dimensional
information built into it yeah it's
exactly the same as this theory of
gravity in more dimensions
yeah so one of the things I like to
think of it with holography is that I
can pack a certain amount of information
about Cole I mean you can literally
think of as like storing things into it
let's say I have information and some
volume and I'm under the illusion that I
could just keep packing information in
that volume as much as the volume will
contain eventually I'll make a black
hole and I'll find out what the maximum
amount of information I can pack into
anything in the entire universe is what
I can pack on the area right and since
areas projecting the illusion maybe a
volume maybe the whole world is just a
hologram it's not a principle that only
applies to black holes it's saying that
if this theory of quantum gravity is
correct then this whole three
dimensionality is an utter illusion and
really the universe is two-dimensional
and as practice speaking you mentioned
before in a conversation that it's
really interesting the Heisenberg
uncertainty principle is a practical
limit now and microchips yeah and if we
make microchips much much smaller than
they already are even as they already
are
it causes errors because you don't know
that bad Johnson if holography if this
limit on how much information you can
ever pack if that ever became a limit as
far as we know that's an absolute limit
right we started off with with clay
tablets not so much information yeah
okay yeah but then we had written stuff
it's getting better and psychic videos
with thin paper that's even better
CDs
dancer interns renovation eventually
make a black hole at some point you try
to fill up your encyclopedia with
knowledge and the most knowledge you
ever have would only be a
two-dimensional on a two-dimensional
surface right and as big as the universe
and then you're done yeah so you know
it's not likely that we're gonna hit
that limit any time soon do you think
it's possible that gravity is really
ultimately just quantum mechanics and
doesn't exist at all in the fundamental
ways that we've been talking about so
far like the Newtonian way and the
space-time way that those are just these
kind of macroscopic illusions and
sometimes I talk about in terms of
temperature temperature it's not a thing
there's no single thing called
temperature right it's a macroscopic
illusion that comes from the collective
behavior really quantum behavior of
random motions of atoms and is it
possible at the whole of gravity is like
some kind of emergent illusion from
what's really quantum phenomena
underlying it well if we buy the idea of
holography then absolutely that's for
sure that's what that's what it's
telling us although which side is the
illusion and which that is the reality
right they're the same I mean
temperatures still great to talk about
doesn't mean we shouldn't talk about
temperature I mean we should absolutely
adjust your thermostats and talk about
temperature but if we look at it closer
and closer and closer we realize there's
not a thing in the world that has a
quantum value temperature yeah
isolated and so maybe there is no such
thing as gravity isolated from quantum
mechanics right so I guess with the
holographic description we've got two
sides which are which are actually
secretly the same on one side there's
definitely not gravity on the other side
well it's a quantum theory of gravity
whatever that means but the point is you
can get it out it's equivalent to this
neighborhood definite so that's like
just saying there's the the idea of a
dual description is just saying there's
a perfect dictionary between these two
descriptions and so to believe or which
ones real is silly it's like saying as
French wheeler is English we all right
yeah oh I like to give is if you take
some extra dimensions and you compactify
them let's say just one all that is it's
exactly equivalent to whatever particles
you had whatever fields you had in your
original theory before you rather you
just add an infinite Tower of new
particles with certain properties that
are all easy to calculate for me it's a
question of which one which description
is most useful I mean if you want to say
gravities and
it's all quantum that's great but then
you fall down the stairs and bang your
head like this description that works
pretty well you don't go to the doctor
about certain defensible cost plus you
raise a fluctuation so there's so many
open questions the fact that there are
all these fundamental issues that we
really don't understand but on the other
hand there's all of these moving parts
that fit together so neatly there's
definitely something that's working here
but ultimately what is going to emerge
from that what structures lying under it
we just don't know but I think the fact
that there are so many fundamental
questions that we just don't know the
answer to that it's an opportunity
that's exciting
it's great thanks so much for coming
thank you good to have you here thank
you very much John it was my pleasure I
[Music]
hope you learned something about gravity
you hadn't thought of before and I hope
even more that it provoked some
questions so thank you for watching
[Music]